hello and welcome to PlayStation great
each week we meet up and go through map
changes in fortnight season X and now
eleven weeks have passed and it's almost
time to say goodbye to the season so
I've decided to put every single map
change in one single video check the
description if you want to jump to any
week in particular but this should get
you ready for the event this weekend so
let's got back two months to August the
first you ready let's do this week one
so season X is about going back in time
forward in time and staying in the
present all the time yes he's an X is
strange the biggest change comes at
dusty with the former meteor hit now
perpetually hanging over us ready to
strike at any second the og containers
have returned and also the factories
this area will be the main focus of the
season compounded by what is floating
inside the rock the capsule of the
visitor and it's already open
round the corner the polar peak monster
has been skewered like an alien shish
kebob at the end of season 9 and now it
remains a growing plant life in the
shape of a butterfly foreshadowing the
end of the season maybe speaking of last
season the orb we saw cracking has now
exploded but immediately paused in time
letting us jump around in anti-gravity
or the mini updates saw random locations
pop up from seasons ago such as risky
reels and not too lazy links an update
to truckasaurus a corrupted building a
big hulking teddy house a gnome house
and a knob to flush factory oh and the
return of the chair structure - and a
billboard hinting at moisty Myers return
and finally down in West world the chair
house was replaced with a TV house it's
messed up this season
thanks epic watch continues through
season X this week the third level of
the structure is now in place and one
final change for the first week of
season X the crushed battle bus from
Fort Nightmares is now an RV remember
this as season 11 will be when the next
fortnight mares is expected to return
and every year the crushed battle bus
moves location
week two the biggest news is the hatred
towards the mechs the community despises
them elsewhere the seasons brilliance
began introducing rift beacons made from
the rocket back in season four
confirming our time-traveling theories
these bad boys absorb the energy of the
ARB and channel that power into what we
call a rift zone the first one of these
this season was found at tilted which
went so far back in time we cosplay as
Cowboys at this tilted building and
harvesting were banned it was great a
sweat free zone other areas to look at
this week we noticed one building
overlooking lucky landing becoming a
shack again strange shizzles going down
this season and yeah ammo I returned
above frozen greasy Grove and the
greatest discovery found in the
wilderness a shack where everything is
upside down but come on we've seen
stranger things happen than this yes I
write my own jokes finally over a dusty
we saw a satellite dish pop up
[Music]
week three another rift beacon has
popped up this time at mega mall which
changed the futuristic shopping mall
into the old G retail row with a twist
though so many husks everywhere
nobody ever dropped here after this week
it was a ghost town
well more like a zombie town but you get
what I mean week three saw one of the
most iconic areas in fortnight
commemorated Kevin's birthplace has a
statue as does his final stand right the
fields
[Music]
over at dusting the furthest container
from the meteor began to be renovated
items were thrown outside and the
makeshift workshop was created the rift
beacons were confirmed to be created
here and for two days a fraction of the
meteor was spotted on a table this all
confirmed our suspicions that the
visitor had returned another awesome
updates are the sweatiest and grandest
and greatest players in fortnight
history to be commemorated both the
winners of the Solar fortnight World Cup
and the duo's were immortalized at lucky
landing and happy Hamlet's these
locations were chosen because they
landed there most often now on to week 4
and yet another beacon popped up this
time at the rec center so I scored a few
goals to say goodbye as two days later
it was gone and I mean gone
nothing replaced it it was a dig site at
best but there were corrupted pick up
items around the site the description in
the patch notes confirmed the rift
beacon malfunctioned and this was not
part of the visitors plan
over at the visitors lair at dusty the
building has evolved massively this week
a walkway added and ultra-modern
workstations to an extra satellite dish
popped up and even a few weights which
now come to think of it was a hint
towards a buff version of the visitor we
also noticed in week 4 that the TV's
over its bond island were slowly filling
up Westworld guess we need to keep
around the TV's in future weeks
[Music]
week five monkey fluffers and out of
nowhere
another RIF beacon popped up this time
in the middle of well nowhere and that
place became Pandora from the
borderlands series complete with a quest
line and this awesome screen filter and
a claptrap to the most annoying back
bling in fortnight history we've also
got to look at the damn star that was
cut in half by the rift zone rest in
peace mr. Diplodocus hang on do you say
Diplodocus or Diplodocus or do you say
Batman watch is almost complete look at
this erection the roof has now been
added what the heck will happen next up
in Haunted Hills a new monument was
added this rock-hard gal a preview of a
skin which came up later in the season
over in dusty once again this week the
visitor was spotted building or maybe
breaking apart mechs scanning each part
individually what the hell is he up to
we shall see soon
week six already time flies and speaking
of flying this week saw the return of
Kevin the cube and his flying island
like usual a rift beacon brought him
back but this time it happened in fatal
fields and fatal fields remains in one
piece
it's a miracle which also means once
he's been round the island he's likely
going to destroy hut watch rip the dream
week six also gave us a hinted crossover
event with the horror film it Chapter
two around the map we found red
ballooned by storm drains
once pops they cackled and scared the
crap out of us over in dusty the mech
parts continued to be scanned and
changed routinely small updates ceased
season for posters found over at
Granny's house and no dancing signs
found bloody everywhere on the map like
they do every season the orbit loot lake
continues to slowly break further and
further and by the way the cracks on the
meteor shines slightly brighter after
this week something is going to go bang
soon so week seven week seven has
arrived and this week it's like meme
world here in a break from tradition the
visitor placed down not one but two rift
beacons on the map which gave us two of
the strangest locations in fortnight
history Gracie Grove returns but every
45 seconds we were fostered dance with
tacos in our hands yeah weird
hmm this tied into the new restaurant
which sells tacos over in Paradise
though we got moisty palms and I mean
that literally that's its name crouching
here turned us into prop hunt objects
including a toilet I told you this was a
really messed up week up the road the
gas station was added for a low-key
great landing spot over at dusty the
building now has scaffolding preparing
for a rocket launch season 4 vibes
anyone inside the scanning continues but
what could he be scanning for oh and
look where the windsock is pointing yep
straight at the meteor it's on mofo what
watch got a lick of paint this week
maybe a coating I guessed it was birch
which allowed me to make a really crappy
joke Hut watch is a son of a birch sorry
okay here's a weird update the ice cream
truck by grandma's house has fallen to
the ground something must be coming to
take its place but what the hell will
that be it's now week 8 Kevin's island
continues to circle the map watch the
lips thankfully but the biggest news of
the week is the unlockable skin became
available the scientist aka thick boy
visitor depending on who you talk to
people believe he's either a new
character or like me they think he's an
upgraded version of the visitor no one
knows for certain not just yet what we
can confirm is the creation of the
rocket here's the bottom section which
gives us a few weeks for the scientists
direction to be ready in the containers
we can also see elements which will be
added over the coming days and weeks at
the end of the week a new rift beacon
popped up inside tilted again and get
this a Batarang had appeared next to it
I actually may get to say holy Sh Batman
with the right context so it's 2 days
later
holy Sh Batman Gotham City has arrived
in a huge crossover to celebrate
Batman's 80th birthday we got to become
the bat and spend time with our parents
oh happy days remember the fall and ice
cream truck it was dumped to make room
for Batman's toys
Daniel Batman week 9 this week the rift
beacon appeared above pleasant park and
a few days later gaybies starry suburbs
originally it was in the first version
of fortnight Battle Royale
but by the time the game became
available to everyone it was gone again
and then in season 2 it came back again
and then a few weeks later it went again
yeah it's a bit confusing how that works
but anyway right now in season X starry
suburbs is back it's fully renovated and
it has falling stars from the sky with
weapons inside the sacred golden SMG
from the trailer can be found in starry
suburbs quite watch ladies and gents I
think this may be the end after six
seasons the small destroyed Shack is now
the perfect watchtower with a fresh lick
of varnish it's been an emotional hot
watch what the hell do we do about time
now we need something to replace it I
have to bite all
hot watch 2.0 begins now over the failed
rift zone for a week for there won't be
enough time for this to be finished this
season so maybe we'll spend another six
seasons together looking at this every
week that sounds good to me for some
reason rush of talk white tour back over
to dusty and it's now complete the
rocket is finished the visitor has
worked overtime to complete this beast
and no I won't be making any rude
erection jokes here I have a question
instead
where will the rocket crash Lunt Uranus
more parts were added over the week but
the big news is that the scan route
parts have found a corruption of virus
in the system from this point the virus
made all falling mechs explode on impact
which made many players delighted
[Music]
week ten the last week right right over
in dusty the rocket has everything added
which is needed before the event and the
control panel became active and
interactive all - every few days the
signal grew stronger maybe the original
visitor is trying to contact the new
visitor and then it happened we finally
got a date the rocket projected the time
and began to countdown as did all the
TVs on the island and yeah that includes
all those TVs at Westworld and now we
wait and see what happens next and now
we're here the final week week 11 we
have the cassette tapes from 1982 find
for extra information about the visitor
the location to have got them starry
suburbs greasy Grove moisty Palms
Kevin's Island and retail row oh there
are rift zones interesting the
recordings were lost in time and maybe
have clues to understand what the hell
is going on on this island for the last
two years here's what we've got so far
but the seven of us are attempting is
very risky
I suspect they are not the only ones
watching but it must be done or we lose
the bridge forever I speculate that no
one calculated the formation of the
island that interdimensional matter
collisions would resolve rather than
push now that I witnessed at first hand
is obvious that pension alone made it
inevitable when we hear this again but
it helped me remember or once looped
will I be just as muted as the others no
matter it seems the lengthy precautions
want theorem was a success I you arrived
outside the loop at the exact moment of
expansion this effectively paused the
singularity giving us time to create the
devices needed to synchronize the
junction as I'm making this video the
last two aren't available in-game just
but there will be in a few hours here's
what they will say what I didn't factor
was the only way to trigger the device
was from within the loop itself thus
this hasty and primitive recording and
why now I find myself looped activate
the beacon and precisely this timer
reaches nothing the zero point must be
contained once more if they are correct
it will be the end
i legit think i know the real story of
four night battle royale right now i'll
wait until after the events to break it
down so do me a favor if this video has
helped you in any way and kept you up to
date with what's going on please use my
code and amaru in the fort night shop
let me know what you want in return what
about more of this stuff every week
thanks to you guys who've used my code
this week and thanks once more to those
people who have used it all season long
you are leggins to me I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade and this was season
X I really hope you enjoy the event
much love see ya
[Music]